même très mal d longevilles mont d'or
dans le jura et royaliste et nous
commandent un micro trottoir ce qui
n'est pas incompatible pourquoi le
stress dans un pays si forte tradition
monarchique nous écrit-elle je m'étonne
parfois d'une méconnaissance aussi
grande de notre histoire de france les
français vraiment ont la mémoire courte
mieux vaut en rire ajoute ces dames avec
philosophie et c'est pourquoi j'aimerais
que gérard pas bio et constater de visu
l'étendue de notre méconnaissance sur le
sujet aussitôt écrit aussitôt fait
régulièrement jacques chirac fait porter
le chapeau aux attentes de faire porter
le chapeau habité rend l inverse
qu'est ce que vous en pensez écoutez
c'est pas moi je vois très bien
mitterrand avec à chapeau oui c'est va
très bien et chirac
pourquoi pas avec un à une casquette oui
c'est va bien mais je trouve qu'il est
bien le style faut porter ça voyez vous
ce qu'on appelle l' odeur de sainteté
monsieur bah c'est reconnaître une femme
qui est enceinte par son odeur qu'est ce
que vous en pensez mais le gens pensent
que toi sont même à l'oeil je veux dire
il n'y a pas de problème on le voit même
avant que ça sens je dirais salle et
vous toujours monsieur sur quel pied
danser sur le tango par le quesnoy un
paso-doble le pour calculer les pieds en
même temps je peux faire une
démonstration si vous voulez la wii
c'est pas difficile
on y va comme ça là vous voyez c'est moi
je suis pas très doué moi pour vous est
de piloter
oui oui mais pourquoi vos yeux c'est une
question qui surprend quand même dans la
rue et surtout de ce temps là et
pourquoi ça paraît évident que d'être
qui le thé c'est à dire
ma cassoulet je vous dise moi tout le
monde je pense que tout le monde est
culotté le sens là c'est normal
culotté c'est quand même pas trouver
quelqu'un dans la rue ce matin qui me
pose ce genre de questions c'est-à-dire
basket vous pilotez je pense que vous y
être que tout le monde y est moi je le
prévois pas non plus à propos de nana
mouskouri que vous connaissez j'aimerais
vous parler du velouté de savoir
j'en ai déjà mangé il s'agit de ce fait
avec de la crème et des champignons qui
sont sans doute de la savoie doit bien
entendu parler du velouté de savoie nana
mouskouri
oui et qu'est ce que c'est c'était je
voulais dire c'est un potage c'est quand
on n'a pas de chance qu'on est dans de
beaux draps
ah bon dans de beaux draps oui mais moi
je préfère pas avoir de chance est dans
de beaux draps que d'être dans la dans
la crotte et que deux sous les ponts je
préfère encore être dans des draps de
soie puis pour voir de chances que
pensez vous des gens qui passent la main
madame n'aime pas vous aimez pas quoi je
me passa même dans le dos sur le bras
j'aime pas qu'on me tripote donc si vous
rencontrez quelqu'un qui passe la main
non moi je refais une gifle que pensez
vous madame des gens qui font chou blanc
mais ces questions des biens de digérer
mais les choux et les choux-fleurs
c'est à dire c'est à dire ces deux
légumes là principalement ça vous arrive
au bout de faire chou blanc quelques
francs à chaque fois que je fais cuire
ces deux légumes et comment faites vous
alors bien je les ai bouillante
je les plonge dans l'eau bouillante et
ensuite je les ai gouttes et je les ai
refait cuir normalement voyez-vous ce
qu'on appelle les feux de la rampe
monsieur oui qu'est-ce que c'est cadeau
la malle au face à face de glisser sur
la rampe
dans quels cas ça vous arrive à des fois
ça m'arrivait oui anne est un gamin
le général de gaulle vous connaissez
vous savez qu'il a connu un moment donné
la traversée du désert oui vous savez
également ce qu'elle a traversée du
désert oui parce que c'est un désert que
vous mais plusieurs motos qui risquent
leur vie et puis
genre c'est le bon courage quand même
parce que c'est pas évident faire ça
c'est ya pas mal de l'accident ni des
motos qui risquent leur vie et général
de gaulle dans tout ça la grosse averse
et l'udf faut quand même pouvoir ainsi
simple puisque c'est la traversée du
désert à saint désert s'asseyait du
sable et bien oui y'a que du ca des
pires beaucoup trop niveau de ça et puis
dans la vie du général de gand enfin moi
disons peu près parce que moi il a quand
même encouragé les personnes pour faire
ça déjà parce que je ne connaîtrais pas
beaucoup d'efforts et ça des chats pour
le général de gaulle j'avais entendu
parler dakar du général de gaulle et
pour tout dire traversée du désert oui
c'est pareil dakar et puis alors le
général de gaulle qu'est ce qu'il aurait
fallu ben je crois qu'il a essayé de
faire la même chose quoi essayer de
participer au niveau des pilotes
il faisait quoi lui ben lui l'état
craint de présenter comment ça se
passait au déroulement dans un
hélicoptère
le général de gaulle général et au paris
dakar et c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
traversée du désert
[Musique]